moria lies in ruins
it was a temporary home for over 12 000
migrants stuck on the greek island of
lesbos
human rights groups had long deplored
conditions in the overcrowded camp
which was operating at four times its
intended capacity
now politicians from around europe are
calling on the bloc's members to take
action
these are horrible pictures that we see
in what has happened in moria
i think it is important now that we
don't leave greece alone with this
today we have already offered the greek
government every support we can
the most important right now is to
protect people and to give them
immediate shelter thanks to quick
reaction from the staff in the camp and
from the
greek police and fire brigade we had no
causalities and no people in hospital
and
of course now the focus is to give
shelter for all these people
tonight the fire was sparked overnight
several shacks went up in flames around
the camp before the entire compound
began to burn
winds reaching up to 70 kilometers per
hour fan the flames
forcing thousands to flee
me how's this finish last fight
many all
finished the inhabitants headed to
nearby hills and woods
others began walking to the island's
capital maitelini
ride police were deployed along the
roads amid fears that the camp's
residents might spread the coronavirus
across the island
last week maury was placed under
lockdown after 35 cases were detected in
the camp
as day broke some residents returned to
search for belongings among the remains
the fire has been put out but over 12
000 migrants could now be homeless
once more in their lives they have
nowhere to go
what's next from moria is a question
many have been posing for years
an answer from authorities has now
become ever more urgent
here in germany pro-refugee groups have
called for nationwide protests in
support
of the refugees from the maurya camp in
berlin at least
three thousand people joined the
spontaneous demonstration which saw
activists march through the city's
government district
activists say several german states
would be willing to offer shelter
to some of the refugees from moria
however
the german federal government has so far
refused
to accept any of the migrants
well joining us now is salam aldine he's
based in here in berlin and organizes
the ngo
in moria called team humanity his
colleagues were on the ground there when
the fire broke out mr aldean you work
with the people who were in the moria
camp
what's their situation now how are they
doing
so um all of the refugees are on the
streets
and we have a community center like 150
meters away from where you can
and we have around 500 to 800 people
in our center and outside our center
most of the refugees went to mithilini
but they were blocked by the police
so if they are sheltering outside on the
streets without blankets without chance
without anything without even food and
water
this is the situation right now this
morning twelve
thousand people the twelve thousand
people sheltering there and moria
are now homeless so what's going to
happen to them what are the plans
as i see it the greek government doesn't
have a plan and they need help
from the whole europe they didn't have a
plan
a few years ago we had many fires before
and we told them
look this will happen and nothing
happened
they didn't even have an evacuation plan
when the fire started there was no
governmental people there were no police
there was not nobody there to help them
so it was only the ngos that was
actually going inside
while the fire was there and taking the
refugees out
so there was no evacuation plan so they
don't have a plan
and still they don't have they don't
know what they're gonna do the last
thing i heard they want to put them in a
military camp
this is the same thing you're putting
him in another camp this is not the
solution
the german foreign minister and other
politicians in europe say
they will put moria high on their
political agenda
what do you think that will translate
into what sort of
action would you like to see
i would like to see that europe take
responsibility
and they will start taking families at
least
first out from that hell they've been
living in for many years
each country can take thousands of
refugees and give them a home
you know these refugees are like me and
you
you know they're humans they deserve
a safe place to be they deserve to be
treated like
humans and the greek government doesn't
do that and europe
must act right now the solution is not
putting them in another camp you're just
moving the problem
to another place with regard
with regard to the fire itself the greek
authorities say that some of the
migrants themselves
may have started it uh why do you think
they might do that
you've been living in a in a camp in a
refugee camp for so long time
and when you hear that they will shut it
down because they said that they will
close it
and make it like a jail people getting
crazy and you have all kind of people
there you know we cannot judge everyone
you have families with children doesn't
even know what happened so
you have some people that started the
fire and then you have
12 000 people running they don't even
know why they're running they don't even
know nothing
so of course people are frustrated
people are tired
people have been living in these
conditions imagine you're living in a in
a summer tent
in the winter with your children without
the heat or without anything
and the government they know that they
got the money from the european union
but they never used it on the refugees
and the money gone
and no one responsibility for them a
desperate situation there indeed uh
salam al-din thank you very much for
talking with us this morning salam
dean is the organizer of the ngo team
humanity in moria thank you
and for more now i'm joined by eric
markvart he is a member of
the greens and a member of the european
parliament mr mark
it's good to have you on the program
you've been to maria before you've seen
firsthand the deplorable conditions
there
did you think that a disaster like this
fire was inevitable was it just a matter
of time
i actually did not only think that this
kind of catastrophe
will happen i already said it in
interviews in march
many humanitarian organizations said
that the situation we have there
is a big problem and that this kind of
catastrophe can happen and
every time so we did not know how this
catastrophe will happen
but that it was just a question of time
when
something like this happens it was very
clear who do you blame for
the conditions that allowed this
disaster
i think it's a difficult question
actually so
of course you can say okay there are
people who
try to put some fires in the camp
and in the end they are
responsible you can say that yeah they
are responsible for setting the camp on
fire
but as a politician and as a member of
the european parliament
who followed the political debates about
the
european asylum system and the
conditions at the external borders
for quite a long time i must say that
i'm not very interested in doing the
police work now and
seeing who did the fire i'm interested
in talking about a situation
where european member states governments
where
also we in the european parliament were
not able to react
to the situation to this catastrophe
and i think in the end it's a political
disaster and we should feel ashamed for
that i mean
this doesn't this expose one of the
european union's greatest failures
i mean this is what happens when some
members of the eu refuse to take in
migrants and leave
other members such as greece to deal
with the reality on the ground
do you agree i would say that it's not
only
few member states who did not relocate
people from greece from the greek
islands especially
it's all of them so there were some
member states who said okay we take some
unaccompanied minors
but in the end we cannot say
okay we have a no unified position
on our asylum policy for quite a long
time for four years
european member states do not find a
position the european commission has a
position the european parliament has a
position and the european member states
are not able
to find a unified position and they are
also not
able to see that when you have
conditions there where there is not
enough
water where there is no education for
the children where
there is no fire protection system that
the catastrophe will happen and that
somebody have to react so it's a
like responsibility not from the
european union and the others it's
the responsibility for everybody who has
a
possibility to help mr mark do you know
who is going
to take responsibility for these
migrants now
what i heard from today is pretty
shocking actually so
yesterday at night i received some
photos for movie i have some friends
there who lived there
and um i said okay it's another fire a
few minutes later i received some other
videos and said okay that's a like
bigger fire
and in the end it was clear that almost
the whole camp was burning and that we
have
13 000 homeless people there who lost
everything
and the situation is that they just have
no
they have not even have a tent to sleep
they have nothing left
and also one day later and it seems that
they have the second
night just without anything and i
i i feel really ashamed as a politician
that
i cannot do something but if i would be
in the german government i would
take immediate action to
help these people make a humanitarian
aids
care of corona but also relocate the
people to germany because there are
enough regions cities and also
bundesliga we want to
well then welcome these people mr macron
earlier this week
13 000 chairs were placed in front of
the german parliament building
to symbolize the 13 000 people living in
the camp that just went up in flames i
mean you were involved with that
demonstration having to wear face masks
has brought
thousands of protesters here to berlin
recently
will homeless burned out refugees in
greece
will they get more attention than just a
bunch of empty chairs
so i come directly from a demonstration
um and this demonstration was five to
ten thousand people
uh who were just shocked by this
not accident but disaster and the
pictures they saw and
five to ten thousand people with noble
mobilization for one day and also in
different
countries in cities in germany where
demonstration
so i think that we should understand
that there are lots of people
who would be very proud when they can
use their
possibilities to help people in need and
i think that
the situation where we hear so much from
the far right where we hear
almost every time when we talk about
migration about the problems of
migration
but where we have a huge
amount of people and possibilities to
help
these poor people and i i think in
like general i don't care about people
like doing demonstration for pace masks
but
i care about the dignity of people about
human rights and i think that they are
the basis
of our societies and i think that
many people are not against the
relocation of these people actually yeah
yeah it'll be interesting to see if
there is any type of public action now
that this camp has been destroyed eric
mark fraud member of the european
uh parliament mr macron we appreciate
your time and your thoughts tonight
thank you
thank you
you